- I'm so excited that
she has come here today.
Bethenny Frankel.
- Oh, oh, you over there. Hi.
How are you?
- By the way, could you
look any more beautiful?
- Flower, flower, flower.
- [Drew] Oh my goodness.
- [Bethenny] I've dressed for the part.
- I always tell that to my daughter.
'Cause her grandparents, they love,
they're a little fancy, and they,
I'm like, elastic sweat
pants and just bad.
And I always tell the
girls they're so lucky.
'Cause they're going to
find their own journey.
I'm like, you might like
actually dressing up
or you might like being
kind of piggy like me.
But I like that I get to
dress the part at work.
So I get that out of my system.
- Same, that's the reason.
- But I always say dress
the part because it is,
there's something that
changes your demeanor
about the whole thing.
- I agree.
And I'm always in pajamas, 99% pajamas,
but that's one of the
reasons that I like to work
because it gives me a reason
to get out of my pajamas
and actually bathe myself.
- You work so hard on so many things.
And before we go to commercial,
I would love to talk to
you about the podcast.
And we're going to talk
about that again more,
but what side of Bethenny
Frankel do we get?
'Cause you have so many.
- Okay, I do have many,
and I did climb my own Everest last night,
a domestic Everest.
I had a glass of wine, a
martini, and a margarita.
(Drew yells)
I made a Long Island iced tea
with three separate cocktails.
- Oh my god, I love that.
That was my big contribution
last night to survive.
The podcast is called
"Just B with Bethany."
It is out right now.
It is literally right
now you can access it.
- It dropped?
- My album dropped.
And nobody that I know that are my friends
knew how to subscribe to a podcast
much less listen to one, including myself.
For everybody over 79, it's there,
but we're beating Hillary Clinton.
It's not like she hasn't
accomplished anything.
- Powerful women.
- Yeah, so I'm excited.
- Sharing like, but you have--
- We're not sharing. I'm
beating her right now.
(Drew laughing)
So, but no--
- Hillary, when you're
doing the debate tonight,
check that out.
You have so much to offer
in entrepreneurial advice.
In fact, we're going to go to commercial
because I have a surprise for you.
- Okay. And then I'm going
to tell you what it is about
and what Bethany you're getting.
- [Drew] Exactly.
- And we'll do it.
All right. Yeah, we have
a little surprise for you.
(imitates evil laughter)
- [Bethenny] Congratulations.
- What?
- This is amazing.
Congratulations. I love it already.
I could tell it's very you.
It's very good. I just
get it. And it's smart.
So congratulations.
- I'm going to go pass out and come back
As the happy little lamb
that I feel like right now
because Bethenny approves,
and I have so much
respect for what you do.
(upbeat music)